[Musik]
es ist nicht klar was mit den daten auf
tik tok passiert ist die besondere sorge
dass eben der chinesische staat darauf
zugriff hat das reichte aber nicht aus
um zu sagen ich mach mir sorgen nein
also mir persönlich nicht sonst wäre ich
nicht auf der plattform es geht um tickt
wegen sorgen um die nationale sicherheit
wollte us-präsident schwamb die app in
den usa komplett verbieten der vorwurf
lautet das tik tok die daten der
userinnen und user sammelt so wie ja
eigentlich jede app die wir auf unserem
smartphone installieren
der unterschied bei tik tok ist aber
dass die app zu einem chinesischen
konzern gehört zu bei dance und deswegen
so lautet der vorwurf könne die
chinesische regierung also die
kommunistische partei zugriff auf die
daten der userinnen und user haben
in den usa hat sich jetzt ein deal
ergeben und zwar so ein us firmen bei
tecdoc mit einsteigen das soll ein neues
unternehmen gegründet werden
tik tok global damit sollen die
datenschutzbedenken die donald trump
hatte ausgeräumt sein
es gibt auch noch andere vorwürfe gegen
tik tok zum beispiel die zensur von
politischen inhalten oder die
diskriminierung von fettleibigen
menschen hier geht es aber jetzt um
datenschutz
der ganze wirbel um tik tok in den usa
scheint der erfolg der app hier in
europa nicht wirklich zu schaden
tecdoc hat jetzt zahlen veröffentlicht
wie viele userinnen und user es in
europa gibt und die sagen dass 100
millionen menschen mindestens einmal im
monat nutzen
ich bin eine davon ich erwische mich auf
mich ab und zu am handy hänge tik tok
öffnen und dann der videos angucken von
welchen leuten die tanzen ihre freunde
tranken oder so und ich frage mich wie
sie jetzt eigentlich in europa aus in
sachen tik tok und datenschutz macht
sich da gar keine sorgen
oder sollte ich die app vielleicht
lieber löschen natürlich gibt es da zwei
seiten ich möchte für diesen film mit
beiden sprechen mit jemandem der
absichtlich keinen tick tock hat und mit
jemandem der die app sehr erfolgreich
nutzt
sehr erfolgreich ist tim walter er ist
bei tik tok herr anwalt und hat mehr als
zwei millionen followern und follower er
ist tatsächlich rechtsanwalt tik tok ist
sein hobby sagt er in seinen videos
beantwortet er die rechtsfragen seiner
community kasse wicke sonne youtube
youtube drin weil er den benni da silva
chicks mit savanne im alter hast du mein
handy das darfst du nicht aber ich
sollte sein vater darf davon reingucken
ist das wirklich so durfte günni von
justus einfach so das handy
kontrollieren eine minute die jura und
die antwort lautet ihr wisst dass es
kommt drauf an und fühlst du dich sicher
bei tecdax deine daten angeht also ich
fühle mich sicher bei tik tok ich hab
momentan auch keine tatsächlichen
anderen anhaltspunkte dass ich las aus
einem grund gebe mich nicht sicher zu
zählen die debatte um eine mögliche
verbannung von tik tok in den usa hat er
auf seinem kanal auch thematisiert
donald trump hat entschieden die app tik
tok zu verbieten und zwar ab montag ab
dem 20 september auch das ist natürlich
ein super wichtiges thema für die
community weil es natürlich die
plattform selbst betrifft große
amerikanische creator könnten
theoretisch nicht mehr inhalte
veröffentlichen und da lag dann der
fokus darauf dass mitzuteilen der
community dass darüber in kenntnis ist
die stimmung war uk bleibt tate opfer
blatt in den usa eine minute sehr geile
nachricht und das jetzt ja auch
geburtstag also hat es quasi geboren in
taxis alles gutes gefühl und die
kommentare darunter klar alle haben
ja also darüber wollen sie sich mehr
gefreut wirst ja man ist auf diesen
plattformen und man macht sich
vielleicht doch nicht so viele gedanken
würde sie ja sagen deine community bei
tic tac die menschen zu denen du da die
du dort erreicht machen sich einfach
keine sorgen wenig glaube ich weil du
für die ist das thema vielleicht noch zu
abstrakt für junge menschen
tatsächlich habe ich das thematisiert
also dass es ums thema datenschutz geht
natürlich die frage ist natürlich immer
ist das wirklich im fokus dieser debatte
oder hat das andere gründe darüber habe
ich jetzt nicht so viel gesprochen weil
ich einfach nicht so viel spekulieren
will die chinesische regierung könnte
eventuell an die user daten gelangen
dann ist ja der vorwurf denkst du das
nicht oder also der vorwurf steht im
raum bisher habe ich aber noch nichts
zählbares dazu gesehen tatsächlich es
fehlt mir also mir fehlt immer das
konkret um wann das jetzt natürlich mal
passiert sein soll dass daten
weitergegeben wurden ich kann verstehen
dass es ihm schwer fallen würde tik tok
einfach so zu löschen
er hat als creator großen und vor allen
dingen auch schnellen erfolg dort es
macht eine menge spaß und vielleicht
auch ein bisschen süchtig grund für den
erfolg von tecdoc ist auch der
algorithmus der funktioniert anders als
der von facebook instagram oder twitter
um zu wissen was bei tecdoc so los ist
muss ich eigentlich nicht groß was tun
die app zeigt mir einfach videos ich
muss plus entscheiden wie lange ich mir
die anschaue und schon hänge ich
minutenlang davor bei facebook und co
ist das anders ich muss erstmal ein
soziales netzwerk aufbauen folgen licon
angaben zu meinen interessen machen das
braucht zeit
bei tecdoc bestimmt nicht meine sozialen
kontakte sondern meine interessen was
ich zu sehen bekommen
basierend darauf welche videos ich wie
lange anschauen und mit welchen ich wie
interagieren youtube funktioniert
übrigens so ähnlich doch weil tik tok
videos nicht länger als 60 sekunden lang
sind schaue ich mir und die app sammelt
in sehr kurzer zeit ziemlich viele daten
über mich ich habe mir die
datenschutzerklärung von tik tok mal
ausgedruckt und mal durchgelesen
das macht ja sonst keiner von euch und
ich habe es ja auch nicht gemacht bevor
ich mir die app damals runtergeladen hat
und darin steht eigentlich ziemlich
genau beschrieben was tik tok sammelt
und warum tik tok diese daten erhebt zum
beispiel klar meine profil dar
den nutzernamen beim geburtsdatum die
e-mail-adresse und das foto all das was
ich ein gebe und hochladen
wenn ich mir das profil anlegen und dann
aber auch um eine nutzungsdaten also
fotos und videos dichter hochladen
die kommentare die ich schreibe
suchbegriffe eingeben oder nachrichten
die ich schreibe und eben auch wie oft
ich mir was wie lange anschauen und wie
ich mit anderen inhalten interagieren
sektor kennt aber zum beispiel auch die
kontakte in meinem adressbuch weiß
welche mobilfunkanbieter ich habe und
tic tac weiß sachen über mein smartphone
die könnte ich so spontan euch gar nicht
erzählen zum beispiel meine geräte id
oder meine bildschirmauflösung und all
diese daten sammele tik tok um mir
werbung anzuzeigen die mich dann auch
wirklich interessiert dass die daten in
die hände der chinesischen regierung
gelangen dafür gibt es keine beweise da
hat herr anwalt recht und auch tik tok
hat den vorwürfen auf meine anfrage hin
widersprochen
nutzer in daten von tik tok werden in
den vereinigten staaten und singapur
gespeichert und verarbeitet
tik tok mit datenzentren von etablierten
anbietern arbeitet tik tok ist in china
nicht verfügbar und die chinesische
regierung hat keinen zugriff auf
nutzerdaten von tik tok nur weil die
daten nicht in china gespeichert sind
heißt es nicht dass von dort nicht doch
jemand auf sie zugreifen könnte den
behörden in china ist es gesetzlich
erlaubt konzerne zur kooperation zu
verpflichten sollte die nationale
sicherheit gefährdet sein
und wenn das der fall ist entscheidet
chinas regierung
sie könnte also bald dance den
chinesischen konzern dem tech talk
gehört dazu verpflichten daten von
userinnen und user herauszugeben auf
meine frage ob das schon mal passiert
ist schreibt tik tok weder hat die
chinesische regierung die herausgabe von
daten verlangt noch würde tik tok dieser
forderung nachkommen
man hat manchmal schon ein bisschen das
gefühl dass da mit zweierlei maß
gemessen wird insbesondere weil wir
tatsächlich auch in der vergangenheit
tatsachen dafür bekommen haben dass es
auf anderen plattformen nicht so gut
lief mit dem datenschutz
und da fragt man sich schon warum jetzt
gerade tik tok die große gefahr
darstellen soll
da ist schon was dran
tram kritisiert tik tok so wie wir
europäer sonst die amerikanischen
plattform kritisieren und wir wissen
sogar dass amerikanische geheimdienste
zugriff auf die daten von userinnen und
usern der amerikanischen plattformen
hatten darüber spreche ich mit moritz
körner er ist eu abgeordneter bin selber
obwohl ich die plattform ganz
interessant finde wenn ich selber nicht
bei twitter
was genau sein problem mit tik tok ist
darüber sprechen wir noch
zuerst geht es um die gründe warum trump
überhaupt mit einem verbot von tik tok
gedroht hatte für viele war die drohung
nämlich nur ein vorwand ich glauben dass
hinter dem verbot von trump sehr viel
eher eigene wirtschafts und
handelspolitik besteht
der möchte einfach diese sehr
erfolgreiche chinesische app da eben
auch sozusagen ein amerikanisch ende
bringe ich glaube das ist schon der
hintergrund wir sehen einfach dass beide
immer stärker das ist gegenseitig
abschotten in china sind ja
amerikanische apps kaum überhaupt
möglich das internet ist da komplett
abgeschottet und sowas ähnliches
erkennen wir jetzt hier auch auf der
amerikanischen seite glaube wir sehen
hier vor allem einen wirtschaftskrieg
einen digitalen handelskrieg sozusagen
zwischen den usa und china das ist
sozusagen eine geopolitische
auseinandersetzung in der digitalen welt
ganz klar dass das dort auch ein treiber
ist der hinter dem verbot und jetzt
sozusagen dem kauf oder verkauf von tik
tok steht unabhängig von dem
handelskrieg zwischen china und den usa
hat moritz körner ein problem mit tik
tok eben weil es eine chinesische app
ist warum ist es so viel schlimmer oder
wäre es so viel schlimmer wenn die
chinesische regierung zugriff auf die
daten hat und den nutzt als setzt die
amerikanische oder europäische regierung
was ist genau das misstrauen also ich
misstraue den chinesischen staat schon
stärker als euro gesten und amerika und
auch dem amerikanischen staat
weil das gesellschaftsbild von china
einfach ein anderes ist china hat eine
autoritäre vorstellung und ein quasi
kollektivistische
gesellschaftsverständnis in china zählt
nicht der einzelne
sondern das kollektiv alle müssen sich
der chinesischen kommunistischen partei
unterordnen
das ist ein völlig anderes
gesellschaftsverständnis und insofern
bin ich da schon skeptischer als
beispielsweise auch amerika untersagen
befürchtet wird zum beispiel dass china
userinnen und user ausspioniert und
überwacht oder die daten nutzt um die
öffentliche meinung zu beeinflussen
um das auszuschließen und zu klären ob
sich tik tok an die in europa geltenden
datenschutz grund verordnung hält hat
sich moritz körner dafür eingesetzt dass
die europäischen datenschutzbehörden
genauer hinsehen und tatsächlich haben
sie im juni dafür extra eine tik tok
task force gegründet um einen
umfassenderen überblick über den schutz
und die praktiken von tik tok in der
gesamten eu zu erhalten was die genau
jetzt untersuchen
das kann ich ihnen leider dass ich auch
nicht sagen geschlossen sie sagen es
gebe keine auskunft über laufende
ermittlungen
sie haben ja ich mich aber informiert
dass hier inspect dieses fonds
aufgesetzt haben wir werden als jetzt
aber im europäischen parlament in den
nächsten wochen auch wieder zum thema
machen
auch im ausschuss in ausschusssitzungen
ist und darüber nach was sind da genau
jetzt die entsprechenden ermittlungen in
welche richtung gehen dass welche sorgen
sind da aber bislang ist da der
europäische datenschutz ausschuss ein
bisschen zugeknöpft auf nachfragen auf
meine anfrage an das european data
protection bord bekomme ich diese
antwort da die task-force erst kürzlich
eingerichtet wurde ist es noch zu früh
sich zu entwicklungen zu äußern oder
anzugeben wann die ergebnisse fertig
gestellt werden könnten oder in welcher
form diese vorliegt werden
tik tok schreibt mir dazu wir sind zur
zusammenarbeit bereit und wir haben der
task force des europäischen datenschutz
ausschusses unsere unterstützung
angeboten
das sieht jetzt so aus dass
möglicherweise nach eher lang geht und
dann wäre die inländische daten wieder
zuständig das ist etwas schwierig und
sie sind auch nicht so ganz so
transparent was sie genau ermitteln und
wo genau da die prozesse liegen aber es
weise könnten eben auch stark durch
strafzahlungen drohen steckt ob denn die
euro die da zur unterordnung lässt eben
genau dieses strafzahlungen ja auch zu
konkrete beweise lägen europas
datenschützer bisher also auch nicht vor
und eine untersuchung scheint sich
schwierig zu gestalten aber allein dass
es die tik tok task force gibt ist für
moritz körner ein gutes zeichen dass so
was passiert eigentlich nicht so dass
ich die nationalen daten sofort mit
einer neuen app sozusagen beschäftigen
und zusammensetzen das heißt das scheint
etwas zu geben und so lange das aus
meiner sicht nicht geklärt ist würde ich
auch nicht auf die top gehen finde ich
absolut legitim moritz körner kann sich
ja schlecht für eine untersuchung von
tik tok stark machen und dann aber auf
der plattform seien außerdem hat auch in
deutschland der bundesbeauftragte für
datenschutz und informationsfreiheit
seine sorgen geäußert
er schreibt vor allem die speicherung
der daten in drittstaaten die nicht den
europäischen regelungen zum datenschutz
unterliegen ist kritisch zu betrachten
userinnen und user müssten sich darüber
im klaren sein dass eine vielzahl ihrer
daten in einem drittstaat außerhalb des
anwendungsbereiches der datenschutz
grund verordnung übertragen und dort
gespeichert werden
wie alle anderen anbieter ist tipptopp
den jeweiligen nationalen recht
unterworfen
auch was eventuelle pflichten zur
zusammenarbeit mit strafverfolgungs und
sicherheitsbehörden betrifft diese
können weit über die in europa üblichen
zwecke hinaus gehen
der sprecher schreibt auf meine anfrage
aber auch derzeit gibt es keinen anlass
für eine spezifische warnung vor der
nutzung von tik tok durch den
bundesbeauftragten für den datenschutz
und die informationsfreiheit und es sei
positiv zu bewerten das tik tok den
umgang mit den userinnen daten
transparent beschreiben
deswegen verstehe ich auch herr anwalt
als großer erfolgreicher creator war ja
sehr vorsichtig mit seinen äußerungen zu
tik tok
trotzdem ist er sich den vorwürfen
bewusst und würde seine meinung zu tik
tok auch ändern man muss das beobachten
und
man muss die aktuellen tatsachen immer
werten und die würde ich dann auch neu
bewerten wenn tatsachen aufs tableau
kämen
okay das heißt wenn es belege dafür gäbe
dann würdest du dir dann doch zweimal
überlegen ob du dick hat das genau also
ich würde mir die die belege ansehen ich
würde mir anschauen was ich davon halte
und dann dementsprechend mein verhalten
anpassen
genauso moritz kerner und solange das
aus meiner sicht nicht geklärt ist würde
ich auch nicht auf den kopf gehen
aber ausschließen würde würde ich das
nicht für die zukunft weil wenn sich
eine app an entsprechende regeln kann
als held dann kann man auch mit der
zusammenarbeiten sollen die ihnen
vertraut verteufeln und ich will nicht
einfach nur sagen man soll das verbieten
das ist mir zu einfach
ich will dass man sich an die
entsprechenden datenschutzregeln hartz
iv erhält
ich bin hin und hergerissen ich weiß tik
tok sammelt meine daten ich weiß die app
gehört zu einem chinesischen konzern und
für mich macht das einen unterschied
trotzdem gibt es keine beweise für die
vorwürfe
und deswegen bin ich gespannt was die
europäischen datenschützer rinnen und
datenschutz herausfinden werden auch
wenn das bestimmt noch eine weile dauern
wird
was sagt ihr tick tack löschen macht ihr
es oder macht es nicht schreibt es doch
mal in die kommentare
[Musik]